I predicted that in within a decade or two that the human species would establish communication with another species. Terrestrial, possibly extraterrestrial, but most probably marine. So we call it the physical isolation tank. Currently there is somebody inside this tank so that you can see what it's like. I think he was in here. Well all I can say is I recommend that you get terrorist-ridden because it is the jet fuel which will carry you farther into the various states and farther out into the universes than anything else will. Deleting memory, schizophrenic, what are you talking about? I'm talking about the treatment that would turn your prisoners of war into like-minded allies. With regards to your own people,
我曾预言，在十年或二十年内，人类将与另一个物种建立交流。可能是地球上的，也可能是外星的，但最可能是海洋生物。所以我们称之为物理隔离舱。目前舱内有人，这样你就能看到它是怎样的。我想他当时就在里面。我只能说，我建议你尝试一下，因为它是能带你深入各种状态、带你飞向比任何事物都更遥远的宇宙的喷气燃料。删除记忆，精神分裂，你在说什么？我说的是那种能把你的战俘变成志同道合盟友的疗法。关于你们自己的人民，
I'm talking about a treatment that would liberate them from erroneous ways of thinking. Kindly continue. The race to conquer the human brain, as well as the nuclear race, will determine our future. It looks as though the communists have already made a start. If we want to be fast and efficient, we have to learn from our enemies and forget morality and ethics. And as long as we continue to stir up fears of the Red Menace, we'll have the population on our side. I assume the CIA already has the green light from Washington for this research project.
我说的是一种能将他们从错误思维方式中解放出来的疗法。请继续。征服人类大脑的竞赛，就像核竞赛一样，将决定我们的未来。看起来共产党人已经开始了。如果我们想快速高效，就必须向敌人学习，抛弃道德和伦理。只要我们继续煽动对“红色威胁”的恐惧，民众就会站在我们这边。我想中央情报局已经从华盛顿获得了这个研究项目的绿灯。
I want all of the American people to understand that it is understandable that the American people cannot possibly understand. It's 1954 and a wild haired man is aiming a strange contraption made of hollow tubes open at both ends up at the sky. Behold Wilhelm Reich and his Cloudbuster, an array of metal tubes that he claimed could harness the power of cosmic orgone energy. Orgone is orgasms essentially. Reich took Freudian psychoanalysis and then extended it to be a cosmology. If everything comes from the power of sex and the repression of it. If healing comes from acknowledging how sex is the reason for everything, you know, there's that trope about how if you extend any model of psychology
我希望所有美国人民都能明白，美国人民无法理解这一点是可以理解的。那是1954年，一个头发蓬乱的男人正对着天空瞄准一个奇怪的装置，它由两端开口的空心管组成。看看威廉·赖希和他的“云爆器”吧，这是一组金属管，他声称可以驾驭宇宙奥尔贡能量的力量。奥尔贡本质上就是性高潮。赖希采用了弗洛伊德的精神分析法，并将其扩展为一种宇宙学。如果一切都源于性的力量及其压抑，如果治愈源于承认性是万物的原因，你知道，有一个比喻说，如果你扩展任何心理学模型，
indefinitely it will become a cosmology. Well, Reich did that with Freudian psychology in the same way that Jung would try to do with Jungian psychology through his conversations with people who knew how to do the stuff well that he was bad at. What most therapists and social workers like myself are bad at, like math, do conversations with mathematicians and quantum physicists like Wolfgang Pauli and Einstein. Reich did that with Freudian psychology, meaning that he thought that there was something that was powering the atoms, that was powering the soul, that was powering the cells,
无限期地扩展，它就会变成一种宇宙学。嗯，赖希用弗洛伊德心理学做到了这一点，就像荣格试图通过与那些擅长他所不擅长之事的人交谈，来处理荣格心理学一样。大多数像我这样的治疗师和社会工作者不擅长的事情，比如数学，就去和沃尔夫冈·泡利和爱因斯坦这样的数学家和量子物理学家交谈。赖希用弗洛伊德心理学做了同样的事，这意味着他认为有一种东西在驱动原子，在驱动灵魂，在驱动细胞，
that somehow was like orgasms, orgasm energy at a molecular level. And he believed that this mysterious life force that he called organ was associated with with sex but it could heal cancer, it could also do psychotherapy things, it could also manipulate weather, and then by the end of his life he thought that it could shoot down UFOs that only he could see with the organ energy by telling people where the UFOs were and then shooting that work on energy at them through tubes. Anyway this is Reich. He was once Freud's most promising student and then who discovered later that trauma lives in muscles which is a profound realization. He mapped how the body can hold on to pain which is one of the places where he wasn't wrong. Now he's shooting at aliens but alas, you know,
某种程度上就像性高潮，分子层面的性高潮能量。他相信这种他称之为“奥尔贡”的神秘生命力与性有关，但它能治愈癌症，也能进行心理治疗，还能操纵天气，到了晚年，他甚至认为它可以通过告诉人们不明飞行物的位置，并用管子向它们发射奥尔贡能量，来击落只有他能看见的不明飞行物。总之，这就是赖希。他曾是弗洛伊德最有前途的学生，后来发现创伤存在于肌肉中，这是一个深刻的认识。他绘制了身体如何保持痛苦的图谱，这是他没有错的地方之一。现在他在向外星人射击，但唉，你知道，
Reich's climatic battle against the evil space invaders was cut short by this more earthly foe. There was a long time where Reich had convinced everyone on his farm, namely his kids and friends, that there were UFOs assaulting the earth but if you aimed these tubes at the weather, not only could you control weather and bust clouds, but you could also shoot the aliens down, and he was one of the only things protecting the US. which were just sort of like wooden boxes that were lined with aluminum foil. He thought that people generated orgasms, therefore people generated organ. But organ also could cure psychology and problems and then cancer. So if you sat in the box, you didn't just get hot from there being, you know, aluminum foil and wood around you. You were reflecting your own orgasmic potential back at yourself until it cured things. Like I said in the 56, the FDA says that's wrong and they say they're fraudulent devices.
赖希与邪恶太空入侵者的巅峰对决被这个更世俗的敌人打断了。有很长一段时间，赖希让农场里的每个人，也就是他的孩子和朋友们，都相信有不明飞行物在袭击地球，但如果你把这些管子对准天气，不仅可以控制天气和驱散云层，还可以击落外星人，他是保护美国的少数人之一。那些装置其实就是内衬铝箔的木箱。他认为人会产生性高潮，因此人会产生奥尔贡。但奥尔贡也能治愈心理问题和癌症。所以如果你坐在盒子里，你不仅仅是因为周围有铝箔和木头而感到热。你是在将自己的性高潮潜能反射回自己身上，直到它治愈了某些东西。正如我所说，在56年，美国食品药品监督管理局（FDA）说这是错误的，并称它们是欺诈性设备。
Reich himself would die in prison just a year later. His once promising career in psychiatry was reduced to a historical footnote, a cautionary tale of scientific and hubris run amok. But this was also after he got into a fight with Einstein about how the orgasms should be informing quantum physics more. Einstein shows up at Reich's farm. Based on some of his claims, he runs a couple tests, concludes that there's nothing measurable to the claims. Reich sends him letters for the rest of his life. He doesn't really get a letter back from Einstein. This is maybe one of the reasons why Jung and Einstein's correspondence is confirmed, is confined to like a dinner party that is confirmed and then maybe a visit at
赖希本人在一年后死于狱中。他曾经充满希望的精神病学职业生涯沦为一个历史注脚，一个科学和傲慢失控的警示故事。但这发生在他与爱因斯坦争论性高潮应该如何更多地为量子物理学提供信息之后。爱因斯坦出现在赖希的农场。根据他的一些主张，他进行了一些测试，得出结论认为这些主张没有任何可测量的依据。赖希余生都在给他写信。他并没有真正收到爱因斯坦的回信。这也许就是为什么荣格和爱因斯坦的通信被局限在一次确认过的晚宴，以及可能的一次访问，
Bollingen that has been reported by a lot of people but not also ever confirmed in something that was written so who knows if that happened. Anyway, could it be that Reich was on to something after all though? That he stumbled on some kind of hidden truth about bodily basis of mental life, a somatic reality that some of his other weirdness made other people write off. That he probably did notice before anyone else that this focus on a cognitive and linguistic dimension of experience and what would later become CVT but at the time was psychoanalysis was losing sight of a more primal reality that was the pathway into
在博林根的访问，很多人都报道过，但从未在书面记录中得到证实，所以谁知道那是否发生过。总之，有没有可能赖希终究是发现了什么？他是否偶然发现了一些关于心理生活身体基础的隐藏真理，一种躯体现实，而他的一些其他怪异行为让其他人对他不屑一顾。他可能比任何人都先注意到，这种对经验的认知和语言维度的关注，以及后来成为认知行为疗法（CBT）但当时是精神分析的东西，正在忽视一种更原始的现实，而那才是通往
healing trauma. So Reich had noticed something and that all these Viennese psychoanalysts that would later excise him from the community had missed. Reich was noticing that Freud was listening to words, where Reich was watching bodies. A lot of time bodies when they made words. A depressed patient slumped. An angry one clinched. Trauma victims held their breath or took shorter breaths that didn't fill the lungs, limited
治愈创伤的途径。所以赖希注意到了这一点，而所有后来将他从社区中剔除的维也纳精神分析学家都错过了。赖希注意到弗洛伊德在听文字，而赖希在观察身体。很多时候，身体在发出文字时（也在表达）。抑郁的病人会瘫软。愤怒的病人会紧握拳头。创伤受害者会屏住呼吸或呼吸短促，无法充满肺部，限制了
the heart rate to faster pumping, upregulated the polyvagal response. A lot of things that we have language for now that Reich was intuiting at the time. So trauma victims often pulled their shoulders up. They armored their hearts, or what Eastern medicine practitioner might call the Anahata chakra. They had tension across the chest. A borderline patient,
心率以加快泵血，上调多迷走神经反应。我们现在有语言描述的很多事情，赖希当时都在凭直觉感知。所以创伤受害者经常耸肩。他们武装自己的心脏，或者东方医学从业者可能称之为“心轮”。他们的胸部有紧张感。边缘型人格障碍患者，
or what we would now diagnose in the biomedical model as a borderline patient, a lot of the time was experiencing a constriction of the heart, feeling a black hole sucking in the chest, which is a pretty common somatic complaint of people with that sort of attachment style. The body wasn't just carrying the mind around. The body was the important parts of the mind because the mind was more of a CPU or central processing unit. The GPU of the brainstem
或者我们现在在生物医学模型中诊断为边缘型人格障碍的患者，很多时候会经历心脏的收缩，感觉胸口有一个黑洞在吸入，这是这类依恋风格的人相当常见的躯体主诉。身体不仅仅是承载着心灵。身体是心灵的重要组成部分，因为心灵更像是一个中央处理器（CPU）。脑干的图形处理器（GPU）
that was controlling our physical responses which informed and colored our emotional reality were all being controlled by something that we weren't aware of a lot of the time. It had learned how to remember things and if we were gonna heal trauma we had to learn how to remember how to feel emotion in a different way. Reich called this character armor. So chronic muscular tension that protected against unbearable feelings was something that he would pay more attention to than what Freud would, which is you know how you wanted to have sex with your family, or what Jung would pay attention to, which is how you wanted to
控制着我们的身体反应，这些反应塑造并影响了我们的情感现实，而这一切在很多时候都是由我们未曾察觉的东西所控制的。它学会了如何记忆事物，如果我们想要治愈创伤，就必须学会如何以不同的方式去感受情绪。赖希称之为“性格盔甲”。因此，保护自己免受难以忍受的情绪影响的慢性肌肉紧张，是他比弗洛伊德（你知道，他关注的是你想和家人发生性关系）或荣格（他关注的是你想如何）更关注的东西。
experience your dreams and myths and things like that. Your rigid neck wasn't just tight, Toreik, it was holding back years of unshed tears and you needed to cry. Your clenched jaw wasn't just TMJ, it was swallowing or clenching back decades of unspoken rage and things that you weren't allowed
体验你的梦境、神话之类的东西。对赖希来说，你僵硬的脖子不仅仅是紧绷，它还压抑了多年未流的泪水，你需要哭泣。你紧咬的下颚不仅仅是颞下颌关节紊乱（TMJ），它是在吞咽或压抑几十年来无法言说的愤怒，以及那些在
to say during an abusive environment of being a child or being in an abusive relationship structure. For Reich, mental illness was quite literally a case of stuckness. It was a damming up of life force in the muscles and the tissues. And the key to mental health was to break down this armor, to release the blocked energy through deep breathing,
童年受虐环境或受虐关系结构中不被允许说出来的事情。对赖希来说，精神疾病实际上就是一种“卡住”的状态。这是生命力在肌肉和组织中的淤积。而心理健康的关键在于打破这种盔甲，通过深呼吸、
physical manipulation, and unrestrained emotional expression in an environment that was allowed. So if this sounds a little bit like Tantric Yoga mixed with primal scream therapy and some stuff from the 70s, that's not terribly far off because Reiki and psycho psychoanalysis or Reichian somatic therapy later turned into bio-energetics therapy, later turned into several models that would inform things like Bessel-Wanderkulk, whether or not he's aware of that influence, that's where it comes from.
身体操纵和在被允许的环境中进行不受限制的情感表达来释放被阻滞的能量。所以，如果这听起来有点像密宗瑜伽混合了原始呐喊疗法和70年代的一些东西，那并不离谱，因为赖希疗法和精神分析，或者后来的赖希躯体疗法，后来变成了生物能量疗法，后来又变成了几种为贝塞尔·范德考克（Bessel van der Kolk）等人提供参考的模型，无论他是否意识到这种影响，这就是它的来源。
But here's the thing, Reich was the first somatic psychologist. He was the first to say that the body remembers what the mind forgets, and the first to work directly with the physical holding pattern of trauma and all those Viennese intellectuals that talked about the unconscious, Reich found it in a way that was a lot more perceivable than the sort of esoteric and subjective stones that they were trying to turn over with their fancy conceptualizations. It was right there on your shoulders. Born March 24, 1897 in Galatia, William Reich was a child prodigy with a restless spirit. He immersed himself in medicine, psychoanalysis, he became one
但重点是，赖希是第一位躯体心理学家。他是第一个说“身体记得心灵所遗忘的东西”的人，也是第一个直接处理创伤的身体保持模式的人。在所有那些谈论潜意识的维也纳知识分子中，赖希以一种比他们试图用花哨的概念化所翻开的那些深奥且主观的石头更可感知的方式发现了它。它就在你的肩膀上。威廉·赖希于1897年3月24日出生在加利西亚，是一个有着不安灵魂的神童。他沉浸在医学和精神分析中，最初成为
of Freud's crown jewels at the psychoanalytic institutes originally, but Reich had a problem. Well, Reich had a couple problems. Like, probably he had something that we would now call schizoid personality disorder. He was brilliant and he was kind. He was devoted and he was a healer. He never directly experienced psychosis, but he did have tendencies towards very entrenched beliefs that did not change when objective evidence said that they might not be right. He often had trouble reality testing his intuition or communicating his ideas and he found it difficult to abandon his failed theories or compromise. He also was right about a lot of things that we still are wrong
弗洛伊德在精神分析研究所的掌上明珠之一，但赖希有一个问题。嗯，赖希有几个问题。比如，他可能患有我们现在所说的分裂型人格障碍。他才华横溢，心地善良。他专注且是一位治疗师。他从未直接经历过精神病，但他确实倾向于持有非常根深蒂固的信念，即使客观证据表明它们可能不正确时，这些信念也不会改变。他经常难以对自己的直觉进行现实检验，也难以表达自己的想法，他发现很难放弃失败的理论或做出妥协。他在很多我们仍然错误的事情上
about. The Mass Psychology of Fascism, which is one of his books that doesn't have anything to do with what I'm talking about here, is still highly relevant. And to say that he was once brilliant and then went crazy is not correct because he maintained a pretty acerbic wit and clarity throughout his entire life. There is no point where his writing became incoherent. There is no point where it became misguided or strange or schizoid. He stayed more or less pretty coherent, whether or not you agree with everything that he believed,
也是正确的。《法西斯主义的群众心理学》是他的一本书，与我在这里谈论的内容无关，但仍然高度相关。说他曾经才华横溢后来疯了是不准确的，因为他一生都保持着相当尖刻的机智和清晰。他的写作从未变得支离破碎。从未变得误导、奇怪或分裂。他或多或少保持得相当连贯，无论你是否同意他所相信的一切，
which I certainly don't. He believed it in a way that was coherent to him and didn't ever become even as selective or cherry-picked or inconsistent as somebody like Freud or Jung. He often had trouble with governments with expressing himself. But he wanted more sex in psychoanalysis than even Freud did. Reich argued that repressed sexual energy led to psychological disturbances and physical tensions. He kept the Freudian route that the reason for trauma was sexual even though he
我当然不同意。他以一种对他而言连贯的方式相信这些，并且从未变得像弗洛伊德或荣格那样具有选择性、片面或不一致。他经常在表达自己方面与政府发生冲突。但他比弗洛伊德更希望在精神分析中加入性。赖希认为，被压抑的性能量会导致心理障碍和身体紧张。他保留了弗洛伊德的路线，即创伤的原因是性的，尽管他
transcended the time that he was in and the modern psychoanalytic conceptualization of his time by noticing that it was held in the body when most psychoanalysis wouldn't pick up on that for another hundred years. He thought that sexual repression created this stagnation where energy got trapped in the body and it manifested as these physical symptoms that related to mental symptoms. He felt that a fully satisfying orgasm released the spent up energy and led to emotional catharsis and well-being in a way that was sort of Victorian that probably isn't the cure. Something like the way they used to treat histrionic women by giving them an orgasm is not effective. But noticing that there
超越了他所处的时代和他那个时代的现代精神分析概念化，注意到它被保存在身体里，而大多数精神分析在接下来的100年里都不会注意到这一点。他认为性压抑造成了这种停滞，能量被困在身体里，并表现为与心理症状相关的身体症状。他认为，一次完全满足的性高潮可以释放积压的能量，并带来情感宣泄和幸福感，这在某种程度上是维多利亚时代的，可能并不是治愈方法。像过去通过给予性高潮来治疗歇斯底里女性那样的方法是无效的。但注意到
is a somatic relationship to emotion is real and something that even modern psychology struggles to reconcile with its its modern you know obsession with empiricism. So regular fulfilling orgasms to Reich meant a balanced psychology, increasing vitality and greater emotional expression. Orgasms weren't just pleasurable, they were catalysts for personal growth and self-discovery, getting bad energy out of the body, experiencing good energy coming back in etc etc. But to be fair, no one has conclusively proved that orgasms don't power psychology or atoms yet. It's just that they
情绪与躯体之间存在关系是真实的，即使是现代心理学也难以将其与现代对经验主义的痴迷相调和。所以对赖希来说，规律且满足的性高潮意味着平衡的心理、增强的活力和更强的情感表达。性高潮不仅仅是愉悦的，它们是个人成长和自我发现的催化剂，将坏能量排出体外，体验好能量重新进入等等。但平心而论，还没有人确凿地证明性高潮不能驱动心理或原子。只是它们
probably never will objectively. So in 1930, Reich's unconventional behavior and anger at the Institutes for not noticing his ideas manifests in this confrontational style that alienates him more and more from the relatively passive nerds like Freud and from the greater psychoanalytic community, which was trying to be very academic and not as blunt or aggressive as Reich became. Reich felt marginalized, he was frustrated, and he saw the resistance to his ideas. And so he did what any reasonable person would do. He wore like a huge knife and he carried like a large wooden club and stood outside of the psychoanalytic establishment where he was not invited to one of the the conventions and this was seen as provocative and threatening because it was. The knife for him had some kind of symbolism. For them
可能永远无法被客观证明。所以到了1930年，赖希非传统的行为以及对研究所不重视他想法的愤怒，表现为这种对抗风格，使他与弗洛伊德等相对被动的书呆子以及更大的精神分析社区越来越疏远，后者试图保持高度学术性，不像赖希那样直率或具有攻击性。赖希感到被边缘化，他很沮丧，他看到了对他想法的抵制。于是他做了任何理智的人都会做的事。他戴着一把巨大的刀，带着一根大木棍，站在精神分析机构外面，当时他没有被邀请参加其中一个大会，这被视为挑衅和威胁，因为事实确实如此。对他来说，刀具有某种象征意义。对他们来说
it just seemed like a threat and Reich's growing paranoia and disillusionment about what they were talking about and if they were talking about him marked this breaking point where he was no longer allowed. In 1934, he's formally expelled from the International Psychoanalytic Association, and the incident with the knife became symbolic of his rebellious nature and marked this final rupture between Reich and mainstream psychoanalysis. If you got Reich and traditional psychoanalysis, you would probably diagnose that he had never been noticed by a father figure and was trying to be, but like many of the pioneers of early psychoanalysis, they mistook their own shadow for the rest of the worlds
这看起来只是一个威胁，赖希日益增长的偏执和对他人在谈论什么以及是否在谈论他的幻灭，标志着这个转折点，他不再被允许进入。1934年，他被正式开除出国际精神分析协会，而那次持刀事件成了他叛逆本性的象征，标志着赖希与主流精神分析之间的最终决裂。如果你分析赖希和传统精神分析，你可能会诊断出他从未被父亲形象注意到，并试图引起注意，但像许多早期精神分析的先驱一样，他们把自己的阴影误认为是世界其他地方
or the greater psychology. So once Reich is cast out of the institutes, he doubles down on everything that he thinks. If Freud's sexuality was important, Reich said it's not only important, it's actually everything, even the atoms that make up your skin. He extends Freudian ideas about libido
或更大的心理学。所以一旦赖希被赶出研究所，他就加倍坚持他所认为的一切。如果弗洛伊德的性欲很重要，赖希说它不仅重要，实际上它就是一切，甚至是构成你皮肤的原子。他扩展了弗洛伊德关于力比多的想法，
into this complete metaphysical system and invents the idea of org-on energy. Reich believed that he had discovered this universal life force that flowed through all living organisms, sort of like the force from Star Wars, but a lot more sexual. It's this cosmic energy, it's sexual energy, it's life energy, and the same force that
形成了一个完整的形而上学系统，并发明了“奥尔贡能量”的概念。赖希相信他发现了这种流经所有生物的普遍生命力，有点像《星球大战》中的原力，但更具性色彩。这是宇宙能量，是性能量，是生命能量，也是同一种力量，
made plants grow in clouds form also makes us think. He built a organocumulantors that are boxes made of these alternating layers of wood and metal usually kind of sheet metal as thin as they could make it at the time, cheaply thicker than aluminum foil but like you know tin and things. And it supposedly concentrated this energy in order to treat conditions that the FDA would let her say it didn't treat. Patients would sit inside to cure diseases, vitality, and improve mood. In hindsight they probably benefited from some of the other practices that Reich did at the farm. The organ accumulators were probably not the mechanism of action, but who knows?
让植物生长和云层形成，也让我们思考。他制造了“奥尔贡蓄能器”，这些箱子由木头和金属的交替层组成，通常是当时能做到的最薄的金属板，便宜且比铝箔厚，但像锡之类的东西。它据称可以浓缩这种能量，以治疗FDA后来称其无法治疗的疾病。病人坐在里面以治愈疾病、增强活力和改善情绪。事后看来，他们可能从赖希在农场做的其他练习中受益。奥尔贡蓄能器可能不是作用机制，但谁知道呢？
Reich saw this as this natural extension of psychoanalytic theory into metaphysics and the larger medicine. Freud didn't want to take it that far and never really thought about Reich or talked about him again. The FDA wasn't amused. Einstein was used to hanging out with psychoanalysts. He drank red wine with Jung at a dinner party, maybe goes to Bollingen, according to a couple people, but it's not confirmed.
赖希将其视为精神分析理论向形而上学和更大医学领域的自然延伸。弗洛伊德不想走那么远，也从未真正考虑过赖希或再谈论过他。FDA并不觉得好笑。爱因斯坦习惯于与精神分析学家交往。他在晚宴上和荣格喝红酒，也许去了博林根，据几个人说，但这没有得到证实。
Reich was different though. In 1941, Reich visited Einstein at Princeton and they talked for five hours. Reich explains that his discovery of biologically effective energy is different from electromagnetic energy, but that it's this other form, maybe similar to what maybe we would call dark energy now in quantum physics, that could fight diseases and fascism, but it's not directly measurable. Reich is also really obsessed with fascism and disease being like a similar thing. He makes a whole lot of metaphors and it informs his thinking that the disease that he sees taking over Europe also is, and America, is also related to the way that cancer grows. So you see that happening a lot in the way that he makes metaphors. Einstein agrees that he'll test
但赖希不同。1941年，赖希访问了普林斯顿的爱因斯坦，他们谈了五个小时。赖希解释说，他发现的生物有效能量不同于电磁能量，它是另一种形式，也许类似于我们现在在量子物理学中可能称之为“暗能量”的东西，可以对抗疾病和法西斯主义，但它不是直接可测量的。赖希也非常痴迷于法西斯主义和疾病是类似的东西。他做了很多隐喻，这影响了他的思维，即他看到席卷欧洲的疾病，以及美国，也与癌症生长的方式有关。所以你看到他在做隐喻时经常发生这种情况。爱因斯坦同意他会测试
this organ accumulator in Bragg's basement essentially. And so for 10 days he takes all these measurements trying to see if there's some sort of other energetic principle that he never finds. Reich claims that there's a temperature increase and so that proves that organ energy exists. Einstein's assistant points out that like this is just convection that when you encase something like inside of aluminum that it will get hot and Einstein concludes this is a temperature gradient you didn't discover a cosmic sex energy. Reich responds with a 25 page letter. Einstein never writes
这个奥尔贡蓄能器，基本上是在布拉格的地下室里。于是他花了10天时间进行所有这些测量，试图看看是否有某种其他的能量原理，但他从未找到。赖希声称温度升高了，所以这证明了奥尔贡能量的存在。爱因斯坦的助手指出，这只是对流，当你把东西包裹在铝之类的东西里时，它会变热，爱因斯坦得出结论，这是一个温度梯度，你没有发现宇宙性能量。赖希回了一封25页的信。爱因斯坦从未回信。
him back. By the 1940s, Reich is advocating probably 20 years before America's ready for it that this sexual aberration should be adopted. You know, Alfred Kinsey is probably like in that same camp. He says that people who repress sex also tend to repress other things and then that creates these societal and endemic problems. He also has this tendency to relate that back to the organ energy that he thinks he's discovered. The FDA teams up with the FBI at this point. They're very frustrated that he hasn't ceased and desisted from telling people that these devices treat
到了1940年代，赖希在倡导一种可能比美国准备好接受它早20年的性解放。你知道，阿尔弗雷德·金赛可能就在同一个阵营。他说，压抑性的人也倾向于压抑其他事情，然后这会造成这些社会和地方性问题。他也有这种倾向，将其与他认为自己发现的奥尔贡能量联系起来。此时，FDA与FBI联手。他们非常沮丧，因为他没有停止告诉人们这些设备可以治疗
cancer. The FDA tells him that he's not allowed to do these things anymore several times. By 54 the FDA gets these injunctions against Reich. In 56 Reich defies the court order. The FBI raids his main property. During the raid the FBI takes all of the organ accumulators and the research materials and Reich is charged with contempt of court. He's sentenced to two years in federal prison. The FDA says that he's never allowed to practice again. Reich says he will, he stays in prison because of that, and I don't know, maybe J. Edgar Hoover just wanted all the orgasm energy for himself,
癌症。FDA多次告诉他，他不被允许再做这些事情。到了54年，FDA对赖希获得了这些禁令。56年，赖希无视法院命令。FBI突袭了他的主要房产。在突袭期间，FBI拿走了所有的奥尔贡蓄能器和研究材料，赖希被控藐视法庭。他被判处两年联邦监禁。FDA说他永远不被允许再执业。赖希说他会，他因为那个而留在监狱里，我不知道，也许J·埃德加·胡佛只是想把所有的性高潮能量据为己有，
but it is weird that there is so much focus because there's a lot of people that are pushing, you know, arguably stranger pseudoscience at this time. I'm wondering who it is that Reich made mad. I don't think that organ energy is real. I don't think that organ accumulators treat cancer. But when you look at the amount of attention that was directed at him for the amount of time that it was, there is someone that he must have pissed off. When Reich gets out of prison, he tells people that he can bust clouds and
但奇怪的是，有这么多关注，因为当时有很多推销可以说更奇怪的伪科学的人。我想知道赖希惹恼了谁。我不认为奥尔贡能量是真实的。我不认为奥尔贡蓄能器能治疗癌症。但当你看看针对他的关注量和持续时间，他一定惹恼了某个人。当赖希出狱时，他告诉人们他可以驱散云层，
create rain by aiming the metal tubes that collect orgasm energy at clouds. Strangely enough the same way that he gets rid of rain is the same way that he creates it so I don't know how the orgasm energy knows what to do but maybe Reich could tell you. Reich at this point decides that the UFOs are attacking the earth with orgasm energy but if you make the tube that busts clouds and controls weather then it somehow will make the UFOs go away. The FDA hasn't banned him from making these devices just the organ accumulators so this is allowed for a minute but he also goes back to making the organ accumulators later. He's a kind man, he's an intelligent man.
通过将收集性高潮能量的金属管对准云层来制造降雨。奇怪的是，他消除雨水的方式和他制造雨水的方式是一样的，所以我不知道性高潮能量怎么知道该做什么，但也许赖希能告诉你。赖希此时决定，不明飞行物正在用性高潮能量攻击地球，但如果你制造了驱散云层和控制天气的管子，那么它不知何故会让不明飞行物消失。FDA没有禁止他制造这些设备，只是禁止了奥尔贡蓄能器，所以这有一会儿是被允许的，但他后来又回去制造奥尔贡蓄能器了。他是一个善良的人，一个聪明的人。
Maybe he's enabled too far by his family or had too much charismatic control over them because of his massive intelligence and other areas. I'm focusing mainly on the things that he did that were weird that later inform a broader psychology. He felt like he was doing the right thing and he probably would have benefited from mental health treatment but despite all of these erratic beliefs and behavior he writes poignantly and clearly throughout his life like I said before you know mass psychology of fascism some of the later work they don't really have any hallmarks of psychosis a lot of them are completely when he's not writing about UFOs like a lot of what he's writing about is completely coherent consistent and ideologically
也许他被家人过度纵容，或者因为他在其他领域的巨大智慧而对他们拥有太多的魅力控制。我主要关注他做的那些奇怪的事情，这些事情后来为更广泛的心理学提供了参考。他觉得自己在做正确的事，他可能本可以从心理健康治疗中受益，但尽管有所有这些反复无常的信念和行为，他一生中写作都非常深刻且清晰，就像我之前说的，你知道，法西斯主义的群众心理学，一些后期的作品，它们并没有真正的精神病特征，很多时候当他不写不明飞行物时，他写的大部分内容都是完全连贯、一致且在意识形态上
consistent, as well as like literally consistent and well-organized. His prison letters at the end of his life are talking about his research. He doesn't seem to be slowing down at all. He dies of heart failure at age 60 in Lewisburg Federal Pediatrician. He probably didn't deserve to be in prison and he definitely didn't deserve to die there. He helped many people with somatically stored trauma in the body. One of his approaches was physical touch, Maybe something that later you know we would call like physical therapy or emotional trauma-informed physical therapy, pelvic floor work, a lot of the things that have been evidence-based to treat
一致的，而且在字面上也是一致且组织良好的。他晚年的狱中信件都在谈论他的研究。他似乎一点也没有放慢速度。他在刘易斯堡联邦监狱死于心脏衰竭，享年60岁。他可能不应该入狱，他绝对不应该死在那里。他帮助了许多身体里储存着躯体创伤的人。他的方法之一是身体接触，也许是后来我们称之为物理治疗或情感创伤知情物理治疗、盆底工作的东西，很多已经被证明可以有效治疗
psychologically stored trauma in the body. He would sit across from people much like Arnie Mendel in process oriented therapy and then poke the places that were tight until they released and then help the person express the emotion that was stored there. Peter Levin has a similar technique now, somatic experiencing. There's a lot of providers that are still not comfortable with doing these touch techniques. I'm certainly not. I kind of want the physical to be separated from the mental health part just for my own comfort zone, but I'm not really sure why patients had to be separated from the mental health part just for my own comfort zone, but I'm not really sure why patients had to be in their underwear. Maybe he wanted to see much
身体中心理储存的创伤。他会像阿尼·门德尔在过程导向疗法中那样坐在人们对面，然后戳那些紧绷的地方，直到它们释放，然后帮助那个人表达储存在那里的情绪。彼得·莱文现在有一种类似的技术，躯体体验。有很多提供者仍然对进行这些接触技术感到不舒服。我当然不舒服。我有点希望身体部分与心理健康部分分开，只是为了我自己的舒适区，但我真的不确定为什么病人必须
old tension. I also don't know why Reich had to be in his underwear, but that was something that he would do. Anyway, they would both be in underwear and he would poke you where you were holding somatic tension or he would call it psychic armoring, and then when he busted the psychic armoring by touching you enough, he would help you explore what came out when you started to express what was under the psychic armor. Now as brilliant as Jung's phenomenology was, Jung's map of the psyche with its archetypes and complexes and collective unconscious, it was just that. It was a map.
（在治疗时）只穿内衣。也许他想看到更多的紧张感。我也不知道为什么赖希必须穿内衣，但那是他会做的事情。总之，他们都会穿内衣，他会戳你身体紧张的地方，或者他称之为“心理盔甲”，然后当他通过充分接触打破心理盔甲时，他会帮助你探索当你开始表达心理盔甲下的东西时会出现什么。现在，尽管荣格的现象学很出色，荣格的心理地图及其原型、情结和集体潜意识，它也仅仅是那样。它是一张地图。
It's a frustration that I have with Jung and Jungian literalists to this day that they want the psychoanalysis to be, or depth psychology type psychoanalysis from Jung to be preserved in the same way that it was when the master made it. I don't really believe that that's true. Jung could tell you about your shadow. He could tell you about your anima, your journey towards individuation, he could interpret your dreams, he could analyze your paintings, he could trace your mythological patterns back to ancient Babylonian mythology. If you were into astrology, he would bring your astrological chart into the room and talk about how it was a metaphor for your life. But what then? And how does somebody interpret a map of the soul or techniques from such a map?
直到今天，我对荣格和荣格字面主义者仍有一种挫败感，他们希望精神分析，或者荣格的深度心理学类型的精神分析，能以大师创造它时的样子被保存下来。我不认为那是真的。荣格可以告诉你关于你的阴影。他可以告诉你关于你的阿尼玛、你的个体化之旅，他可以解释你的梦，他可以分析你的画，他可以追溯你的神话模式到古巴比伦神话。如果你对占星术感兴趣，他会把你的占星图带进房间，谈论它是你生活的隐喻。但然后呢？一个人如何解释灵魂的地图或来自这样一张地图的技术？
You'd lie on the couch having professed You know profound insights that didn't necessarily change anything. I think that Jungian psychology probably changed a lot more than the Early psychoanalysis, but it still was just analysis. It was intellectual, it was prefrontal cortex. It didn't really make use of the precuneal insight in the brain that Jung had observed and diagnosed correctly. So understanding your mother complex intellectually doesn't really release it from your nervous system. It doesn't really change the autonomic
你会躺在沙发上，声称你知道深刻的见解，但这并不一定会改变任何事情。我认为荣格心理学可能比早期精神分析改变了更多，但它仍然只是分析。它是理性的，它是前额叶皮层的。它并没有真正利用荣格观察到并正确诊断的大脑中的楔前叶洞察力。所以理智地理解你的母亲情结并不能真正将其从你的神经系统中释放出来。它并不能真正改变自主
nervous systems response to emotion. It doesn't really change the polyvagal system. I mean, maybe you bring it up enough that the window of tolerance shifts, but that's a big if. Even though if that's true for a lot of people, it's not true for all of them. And it also costs a lot of time to talk about these things for so long that you become exhausted by them, and then let go of them, and then feel them a different way. And even if you do have enough money and enough time to do that, it doesn't change for everybody the same. So Jung had given us probably the most complete map of the soul that anyone had ever drawn, but he hadn't given
神经系统对情绪的反应。它并不能真正改变多迷走神经系统。我的意思是，也许你提得足够多，容忍窗口就会发生变化，但那是一个很大的“如果”。即使这对很多人来说是真的，但对所有人来说并非如此。而且谈论这些事情太久也需要花费大量时间，以至于你对它们感到精疲力竭，然后放下它们，然后以不同的方式感受它们。即使你有足够的钱和时间这样做，它也不会对每个人都产生同样的改变。所以荣格给了我们可能是任何人画过的最完整的灵魂地图，但他没有给我们
us a vehicle to really travel it. And it was psychoanalysis, it was depth analysis, but intellectual analysis, and it didn't use the body, it was depth analysis, but intellectual analysis, and it didn't use the body, it didn't engage the brain stem. It didn't work with parts of the brain where trauma actually lives. So Reich had found this vehicle, but he had driven it straight off a cliff into UFO territory, it wouldn't be rediscovered for another 50 to arguably 100 years. If somebody put it together, Jung's map, Reich's method, it would take several disciples talking, it would take a whole lot of psychoanalytic conferences, and these seeds take root in California. So Reich's ideas don't die with him. They went underground, they emerged in the
一个真正去旅行的工具。它是精神分析，它是深度分析，但它是理性的分析，它没有使用身体，它没有参与脑干。它没有处理创伤实际存在的大脑部分。所以赖希找到了这个工具，但他把它直接开下悬崖进入了不明飞行物的领域，它在接下来的50到100年里都不会被重新发现。如果有人把荣格的地图和赖希的方法结合起来，那将需要几个弟子的交谈，需要大量的精神分析会议，而这些种子在加利福尼亚扎根。所以赖希的想法并没有随他而去。它们转入地下，出现在
Californian sun. You know, Alexander Lowen, Reich's student, he develops bio-endrogyetics. You know Alexander Lowen, Reich's student, he develops bioenergetics. He took Reich's character armor concept, he refines it, mapping how different character types held tension. The schizoid splits from their body, the oral collapsed into the chest, the psychopath inflates above the diaphragm. Maybe some of these are overly broadly painted generalizations, but a lot of these things core energetics, biodynamic analysis, somatic experiencing, Hakomi therapy, they're not cranky and they work and they work to treat trauma. These things are going to be put together with
加利福尼亚的阳光下。你知道，亚历山大·洛温，赖希的学生，他发展了生物能量学。他采用了赖希的性格盔甲概念，并对其进行了提炼，绘制了不同性格类型如何保持紧张的图谱。分裂型从身体中分裂出来，口欲型塌陷在胸部，精神病态型在横膈膜上方膨胀。也许其中一些是过于宽泛的概括，但很多这些东西——核心能量学、生物动力分析、躯体体验、哈科米疗法——它们不是怪论，它们有效，并且它们有效地治疗创伤。这些东西将被与
experiential therapy. Jung is more of a map, Reich is more of a somatic practitioner. But it isn't at a loss when there's people in California that are watching these Eastern ideas come in for the 60s that notice that these things look like chakras. They look like other things that are perennial philosophies about somatic medicine that have been discovered in another place.
体验式疗法结合在一起。荣格更像是一张地图，赖希更像是一位躯体从业者。但当加利福尼亚有人在60年代看到这些东方思想进入时，他们注意到这些东西看起来像脉轮，这并不令人感到损失。它们看起来像其他关于躯体医学的永恒哲学，这些哲学在另一个地方被发现。
And they look very similar to somebody who came up with the same ideas in a different way. Cut to 1969. Fritz Perls, the founder of Gestalt Therapy, is at Eastland and he's doing a demonstration. The crowd watches. Fritz Perls has a cigarette dangling from his mouth and he works with a volunteer. What are you aware of right now? He has a thick German accent. The woman mentions her nervousness. Good, be nervous, be more nervous.
它们看起来非常像一个以不同方式提出相同想法的人。切入1969年。格式塔疗法的创始人弗里茨·皮尔斯在伊萨兰，他正在做演示。人群在观看。弗里茨·皮尔斯嘴里叼着一支烟，他与一名志愿者一起工作。你现在意识到什么？他有浓重的德国口音。那个女人提到了她的紧张。好，紧张吧，再紧张一点。
Show me nervous with your whole body. She trembles and she shakes and then she breaks into sobs that seem to come from the center of her being. Half the audience thinks that they're witnessing a miracle. And the other half think that they're witnessing this circus act in the psychoanalytic community that wants to have these complicated Conceptualizations in the late 60s leading into something like Becker, you know They they need this intellect to save them and they think that this is complete Just Exploitation and nonsense the other half thinks that he has found this cure someone shouts
用你的全身向我展示紧张。她颤抖着，然后爆发出一阵似乎来自她生命中心的啜泣。一半观众认为他们正在见证奇迹。而另一半人认为他们正在见证精神分析社区中的这种马戏表演，那些想要在60年代后期进行复杂概念化的人，通向像贝克尔那样的人，你知道，他们需要这种智力来拯救他们，他们认为这完全只是剥削和胡说八道，另一半人认为他找到了这种疗法，有人喊道
Is this therapy or theater and then pearls yells back and a quote that probably haunts him. Yes, it is Pearls trained briefly with Reich he absorbed his ability to notice what the body was doing But he combined it with his Experiential awareness that emotions are the sort of arc that gets stuck, that arc has to be completed, and that when you tell somebody to go through the thing that they are saying is the symptom, a lot of times that it is the symptom that heals them. That sort of conventional wisdom that the only way out is through is something that someone like Pearls understands pretty early. Pearls's early career is marked by things like the theory of dental
这是疗法还是戏剧？然后皮尔斯回喊了一句可能困扰他的名言：“是的，它是。”皮尔斯曾与赖希短暂受训，他吸收了他观察身体在做什么的能力。但他将其与他的体验式意识结合起来，即情绪是那种被卡住的弧线，那条弧线必须完成，当你告诉某人去经历他们所说的症状时，很多时候正是那个症状治愈了他们。那种“唯一的出路就是穿过它”的传统智慧，是像皮尔斯这样的人很早就理解的东西。皮尔斯的早期职业生涯以牙齿攻击理论和非常像霍妮和温尼科特的后弗洛伊德思想为标志，后来他脱离了那个社区，开始看到治愈抑郁症的方法是让人感到如此抑郁，以至于他们认为自己会死，但他们没有，然后你告诉他们深入挖掘，然后你强迫他们穿过抑郁，你强迫他们一直穿过去，在那一面的另一边是意识到我们可以活下来，而治愈一直就在我心中。你也会把皮尔斯与椅子工作之类的事情联系起来，如果你有一堆椅子，如果有人害怕他们的父亲，
aggression and very horn-eye and Winnicott-like neo-Freudian ideas and then later he splits from that community and starts to see that the way that you cure depression is by making people so depressed that they think they die but they don't and then you tell them to go deeper and then you force them through the depression and you force them all the way through and on the other side of that is the realization that we can live through it and the cure was within me all along. You also associate pearls with things like chair work that you get a whole bunch of chairs if someone's afraid of their dad
而不是在沙发上抽烟时谈论父亲，然后分析他们的性幻想，你会在他们旁边放一把空椅子，你说，嘿，父亲就在椅子上，告诉他你恨他。然后那个人看着父亲，他们大喊大叫，经历他们所有的愤怒。他们走到情绪的最底层，最底层，他们说，你知道吗？我只是想让你他妈的爱我。为什么你不爱我，爸爸？然后他们哭了，然后他们治愈了自己，因为他们找到了那种爱，并且他们已经……
instead of talking about dad while they smoke cigarettes on the couch and then analyzing their sexual fantasies you put an empty chair next to them and you say, hey, here's dad in the chair, tell him that you hate him. And then the person looks at dad and they yell and they go through all their anger. They go to the very bottom of the emotion, the very bottom, they're like, you know what? I just wanted you to fucking love me. Why didn't you love me, dad? And then they cry and then they've cured themselves because they've found that love and they've
与其在沙发上抽着烟谈论父亲，然后分析他们的性幻想，不如在他们旁边放一把空椅子，对他们说，嘿，爸爸就在那把椅子上，告诉他你恨他。然后那个人看着爸爸，大声喊叫，宣泄出所有的愤怒。他们深入到情绪的最底层，最底层，他们会说，你知道吗？我只是想让你他妈的爱我。爸爸，你为什么不爱我？然后他们哭泣，接着他们就治愈了自己，因为他们找到了那种爱，并且他们已经
found the root of their suffering internally. He will define modern therapy. Those Jungian archetypes that everyone was analyzing to death, put them in chairs, talk to them, be them, don't talk about them, just experience them. It's a very early way of understanding emotion as an arc of understanding polyvagal theory, autonomic response. It's a very early way of understanding something like the shadow in an embodied way. You want to give a voice to your pain and in giving a voice to your pain you will see what it wants and then you will explore parts of self and then parts based therapy from
在内心深处找到了他们痛苦的根源。他将定义现代疗法。那些每个人都在分析到死的荣格原型，让他们坐在椅子上，与他们交谈，成为他们，不要谈论他们，只需体验他们。这是一种非常早期的理解情感的方式，作为理解多迷走神经理论、自主神经反应的弧线。这是一种非常早期以具身方式理解阴影之类事物的方式。你想为你的痛苦发出声音，而在为你的痛苦发出声音时，你会看到它想要什么，然后你会探索自我的各个部分，然后基于部分的疗法从
the fusion of experiential and somatic medicine will be this inevitable thing that places people places like Harvard will explore with internal family systems through Richard Schwartz and multiple others. Let it speak So suddenly 20 years of analysis could happen in 20 minutes Half of the community is really interested in this as an innovation The other half of the community is really threatened by the fact that it doesn't take 20 years And now they have to come up with a reason why this isn't thorough This is you know there there is still in psychotherapy this distrust of anybody that has a shortcut. Because if you're doing it faster than me, you're probably not doing it wrong.
体验式医学和躯体医学的融合将成为一种必然，像哈佛这样的地方将通过理查德·施瓦茨和其他许多人探索内部家庭系统。让它说话。所以突然间，20年的分析可以在20分钟内完成。社区的一半人对这种创新非常感兴趣。另一半人则感到非常受到威胁，因为这不需要20年。现在他们必须想出一个理由来解释为什么这不够彻底。你知道，在心理治疗中，仍然存在对任何有捷径的人的不信任。因为如果你做得比我快，你可能做得不对。
It's not that I'm bad at it, it's that I'm being more thorough by wasting the patient's money and time. Not always the case. Some things take time, but that's still something that you see in this profession. So, there was this breakthrough that everyone had been waiting for, this fusion. And you take Jung's profound understanding of the psyche's depth, and you add Reich's semantic awareness of it. I mean, admittedly, through lots of inferences that come after Reich, and then you mix in Perl's experiential techniques and this result was this kind of alchemy in the 60s and 70s where this laboratory happened and you got to realize that not everyone is doing the same thing in psychotherapy. It takes people 10 years to get trained and over identify with a model and then think that it's the cure for everything
不是我不擅长，而是我通过浪费病人的钱和时间来表现得更彻底。情况并非总是如此。有些事情需要时间，但这仍然是你在这一行业中看到的东西。所以，每个人都在等待的突破，这种融合出现了。你采用了荣格对心灵深度的深刻理解，并加上了赖希对它的躯体意识。我的意思是，诚然，通过赖希之后的大量推论，然后你混合了珀尔斯的体验式技术，这个结果在60年代和70年代形成了一种炼金术，这个实验室发生了，你必须意识到并不是每个人在心理治疗中都在做同样的事情。人们需要10年时间来接受培训，并过度认同一种模式，然后认为它是万能的疗法
and then get insecure about the fact that it doesn't really work that well and then talk to somebody else and be honest about what they're actually seeing in the room and then learn a new thing. Like that takes a lifetime. It takes 10, 20 years for these things to kind of mix together, but they are mixing from the 60s to the 80s. From the 60s, 70s to the 80s, like they're mixing a lot. Virginia Satir, she took family dynamics.
然后因为这种疗法其实效果并不好而感到不安，然后与其他人交谈，诚实地面对他们在房间里实际看到的情况，然后学习新东西。这需要一辈子的时间。这些东西混合在一起需要10年、20年的时间，但它们从60年代到80年代一直在混合。从60年代、70年代到80年代，它们混合了很多。弗吉尼亚·萨提亚，她采用了家庭动力学。
You know, those archetypal patterns that Jung describes. She becomes the basis for a lot of family therapy. The Minnesota school would split and Salvador Mnuchin would fight somebody else. But she noticed those patterns. And, you know, Sue Johnson and Salvador Mnuchin would fight about should you follow the emotion that Satir pointed out or should you follow the structure that she pointed out. You know, like most things, the answer is usually sort of in the middle and the extremes
你知道，荣格描述的那些原型模式。她成为了许多家庭治疗的基础。明尼苏达学派会分裂，萨尔瓦多·米纽钦会与其他人争吵。但她注意到了这些模式。而且，你知道，苏·约翰逊和萨尔瓦多·米纽钦会争论你应该遵循萨提亚指出的情感，还是应该遵循她指出的结构。你知道，像大多数事情一样，答案通常在中间，而极端
are not always helpful. But this, you know, you look at the tyrant father, the martyr mother, the scapegoated child, find new positions, find new possibilities, new ways of being. Arnold Mendel takes process work or process-oriented psychotherapy as it's sometimes called. And he combines Jung's ideas about the unconscious, speaking through symptoms with Reich's body awareness, you know, backache might be an unlived life, a slip of the tongue might be your true self trying to emerge, followed this dreaming everywhere. And he has this idea that is still incredibly progressive of
并不总是有帮助。但是，你看暴君父亲、殉道者母亲、替罪羊孩子，找到新的位置，找到新的可能性，新的存在方式。阿诺德·明德尔采用了过程工作或有时被称为过程导向心理治疗的方法。他将荣格关于无意识通过症状说话的想法与赖希的身体意识结合起来，你知道，背痛可能是一种未活出的生活，口误可能是你试图浮现的真实自我，到处追随这种梦境。他有一个仍然极其进步的想法，即
realizing that there are different types of memory that you don't have every sort of memory associated with every sort of trauma and You also don't record all of trauma or memory like a videotape Some of it is somatic some of it is auditory and relational Some of it is like sort of interjective and reflexive internally reflexive modern neuroscience bears this out Even though a few people will admit that these people were the reason for it They want to see it like in a lab on an fMRI, but like it's saying the same thing And then how and Sidra Stone developed voice dialogue therapy Which is sort of a precursor of IFS that I think is a little bit more intuitive than IFS is. You know, you could talk to these parts directly. You get the chair work and then you put them around but they're not your
意识到存在不同类型的记忆，你并没有与每种创伤相关的每种记忆，而且你也不会像录像带一样记录所有的创伤或记忆。有些是躯体的，有些是听觉和关系的。有些是内射的和反思的，内部反思的。现代神经科学证实了这一点，尽管很少有人会承认这些人是其原因。他们想在实验室的核磁共振成像中看到它，但这说的是同一件事。然后哈尔和西德拉·斯通开发了对话疗法，这算是IFS的前身，我认为它比IFS更直观。你知道，你可以直接与这些部分交谈。你进行椅子工作，然后把它们放在周围，但它们不是你的
family in voice dialogue therapy. They're pieces of you. So go ahead and talk to your inner critic. Go ahead and talk to your vulnerable child. Go ahead and talk to your pusher self. The pusher just wants you to do one more thing. It wants you to be obsessive. You haven't done enough. You know, the inner critic feels like you need to feel bad, that shame will motivate you, even though you know intellectually that's not true. This part of you still does. The vulnerable child just wants to hide in the corner. Maybe the inner critic and the pusher team up, they yell at the vulnerable child. Let's not make it about dad. Let's not make it about mom. Let's not make it about what happened to you, let's just go ahead and voice the internal systems that are inside of you
家庭，在对话疗法中。它们是你的一部分。所以，去和你的内在批评者谈谈吧。去和你的脆弱孩子谈谈吧。去和你的推动者自我谈谈吧。推动者只是想让你多做一件事。它想让你强迫自己。你做得还不够。你知道，内在批评者觉得你需要感觉糟糕，羞耻感会激励你，尽管你在理智上知道那不是真的。你的这部分仍然这样做。脆弱的孩子只想躲在角落里。也许内在批评者和推动者联手，他们对脆弱的孩子大喊大叫。让我们不要谈论爸爸。让我们不要谈论妈妈。让我们不要谈论发生在你身上的事情，让我们直接为内在的系统发声
right now. Who cares where you got them? These are things that are huge and change, but they come from Jung's map meeting semantic and experiential medicine. Rolf Massage, holotropic breathwork from someone like Stanislav Grof, or you know what's his name, Ken Wilber, you know, perinatal matrices, primal therapy, all of the from the relatively accepted now to the very weird and forgotten, they come out of this fusion. And for a huge part they come out of California
现在。谁在乎你从哪里得到它们的？这些东西是巨大的变化，但它们来自荣格的地图与躯体和体验式医学的结合。罗尔夫按摩，来自像斯坦尼斯拉夫·格罗夫这样的人的整体呼吸法，或者你知道他的名字，肯·威尔伯，你知道，围产期矩阵，原始疗法，所有这些从现在相对被接受的到非常怪异和被遗忘的，它们都来自这种融合。在很大程度上，它们来自加利福尼亚。
Psychoanalysis can't really keep up with the pace of what's happening So what it does is it gets very insecure and it stays in New York and there continues to be this fight At this point largely in the Gestalt therapy community about whether or not psychotics the the the new about whether or not the new application of psychotherapy that we're seeing should be a medical procedure that is done by an expert in a chair, which is the New York perspective, or the California perspective, which should be a new way of life that we understand everything
精神分析真的跟不上正在发生的事情的步伐。所以它变得非常不安全，留在纽约，并且在格式塔治疗社区中继续存在着一场争论，关于我们所看到的心理治疗的新应用是否应该是一种由椅子上的专家进行的医疗程序，这是纽约的观点，还是加利福尼亚的观点，即它应该是一种我们理解一切的新生活方式
in politics and religion and it changes you. Maybe it should be a religion, not a medical procedure. That fight is still probably alive. You can see it on Instagram pretty loud or sometimes on LinkedIn Whether or not you identify as primarily wanting to be seen on LinkedIn versus Instagram may tell you now Which side of this debate you still fall on? Do you think that your psychotherapy is a religious experience or do you think that it is a medical procedure? Do you think that it is a business or do you think it is a new transformative way of life?
在政治和宗教中，它会改变你。也许它应该是一种宗教，而不是一种医疗程序。那场争论可能仍然存在。你可以在Instagram上看到它非常响亮，或者有时在LinkedIn上。你是否认为自己主要想在LinkedIn上被看到，而不是Instagram，这可能告诉你现在你仍然属于这场辩论的哪一边？你认为你的心理治疗是一种宗教体验，还是你认为它是一种医疗程序？你认为它是一门生意，还是你认为它是一种新的变革性生活方式？
So by July 15th, 1979, Jimmy Carter addresses the nation. The threat is nearly invisible in ordinary ways. He says, it is a crisis of confidence. It is a crisis that strikes at the very heart and soul and spirit of our national will. He later gets crucified for this and it probably ends his political career because you're not allowed to tell Americans to question the hero myth or the infinite potential of West bird expansion. You know, a hundred years after West bird expansion and the frontier are over, you still have to be using that language or else you're out. Vietnam.
所以到1979年7月15日，吉米·卡特向全国发表讲话。这种威胁在普通方式下几乎是看不见的。他说，这是一场信心危机。这是一场打击我们民族意志核心、灵魂和精神的危机。他后来因此被钉在十字架上，这可能结束了他的政治生涯，因为你不允许告诉美国人去质疑英雄神话或西部扩张的无限潜力。你知道，在西部扩张和边疆结束一百年后，你仍然必须使用那种语言，否则你就出局了。越南。
Watergate. Oil embargoes. Stagflation. The American Empire wasn't reflecting power anymore back at the people that were part of it. The systems weren't working. Or maybe we needed to come up with a new way of envisioning how systems should work, but don't worry, we never did. What we did was the same thing that all empires have done throughout time.
水门事件。石油禁运。滞胀。美帝国不再向参与其中的人民反映力量。系统不再起作用。或者也许我们需要想出一种新的方式来设想系统应该如何工作，但别担心，我们从来没有这样做过。我们所做的是所有帝国在历史上都做过的事情。
When empires stop making their citizens feel special, these citizens go looking for power elsewhere, mainly internally. Personal power. Mystical power. The kind that Jung had been pointing towards all along. And I don't think that he would have liked this era of history, I don't think that was his point, but he was available in the country, fucking grabbed it. So you have all of these people who no longer feel like the government represents my interest.
当帝国不再让其公民感到特别时，这些公民就会去别处寻找力量，主要是向内寻找。个人力量。神秘力量。荣格一直指出的那种力量。我不认为他会喜欢这个历史时代，我不认为那是他的重点，但他当时在这个国家，他妈的抓住了它。所以你有所有这些不再觉得政府代表我利益的人。
Left or right, I don't agree with what the government is doing, and so I feel alienated and therefore I have to go inward and come up with my own esoteric philosophy that gives me a sense of personal power that leaves me dissatisfied but fulfilled in a way that doesn't happen during times where the empire reflects your ego back at you. Does that sound familiar? Left and right, extreme left and right, don't feel like the government is doing what they want, even if they're holding power at that time. So Joseph Campbell reads Jung and then he writes, even though he doesn't give him credit, The Hero with a Thousand Faces in the 50s.
无论左派还是右派，我不同意政府正在做的事情，所以我感到疏远，因此我必须向内走，想出我自己的深奥哲学，给我一种个人力量感，这让我不满足，但在帝国反映你的自我时不会发生的那种方式中感到满足。这听起来熟悉吗？左派和右派，极左和极右，不觉得政府在做他们想要的事情，即使他们当时掌握着权力。所以约瑟夫·坎贝尔读了荣格，然后他写了《千面英雄》，尽管他没有给他功劳，那是在50年代。
No one reads it. He thinks that maybe that is a red herring, he tries to do some like other stuff with myth, and then all of a sudden his royalty checks jump all the way up in the 60s. All these people think he's great, he's making money as an academic, which is something that's not supposed to happen. And Here With a Thousand Faces is not like the best articulation of Campbell's thought, it's pretty early and it's kind of a boring read. But anyway, he's like calling these people Why are you buying my books? Why are you reading this stuff? And they're like because we're taking LSD and the LSD is telling us that the mythology is inside of us
没有人读它。他认为这可能是一个干扰项，他试图用神话做一些其他的事情，然后突然间他的版税支票在60年代一路飙升。所有这些人认为他很棒，他作为一名学者在赚钱，这是不应该发生的事情。《千面英雄》并不是坎贝尔思想的最佳表达，它很早，读起来有点无聊。但无论如何，他就像在问这些人，你们为什么要买我的书？你们为什么要读这些东西？他们说因为我们在服用LSD，LSD告诉我们神话就在我们内心
And it's making us realize that we need to look at myth and you're the only one writing about that and and Campbell's like, huh I've never tried LSD. A young George Lucas in California reads Campbell. He writes Star Wars. Suddenly, every screenwriter in Hollywood has a Campbell copy on their desk. There's still, I think, like the screenwriter's room in Berkeley is named after him, or library or something, some building, I don't know. If you go to Berkeley, email me. But this hero's journey that we go through these processes of making mythology and that informs the way that we want to have stories served to us through popular media, like comics, like movies. When those things follow this model, they're successful, and they don't have to follow it as much as be in conversation with it.
它让我们意识到我们需要审视神话，而你是唯一一个写这个的人。坎贝尔说，嗯，我从来没试过LSD。加利福尼亚的一位年轻的乔治·卢卡斯读了坎贝尔的书。他写了《星球大战》。突然间，好莱坞的每个编剧桌上都有一本坎贝尔的书。我认为伯克利的编剧室仍然以他的名字命名，或者图书馆什么的，某栋建筑，我不知道。如果你去伯克利，给我发邮件。但这种英雄之旅，我们经历这些制造神话的过程，这影响了我们希望通过大众媒体（如漫画、电影）向我们提供故事的方式。当这些东西遵循这种模式时，它们是成功的，而且它们不必完全遵循它，而是与它对话。
It becomes this idea that culture still hasn't gotten away from. Even something like Rick and Morty is Dan Harmon being exasperated that he has to be in conversation with this model and making fun of it, but he's still talking to it. We haven't figured out a way to get away from the hero's journey. If you're not familiar with it, you may need to look it up. Again, I can't explain every single thing that I reference in a 2-3 hour thing, but this culture was ready for magic. Star Wars is not a science fiction. It is fantasy set in space. Star Wars is not Star Trek. It's not about, oh like the creature is attacking us.
它变成了文化仍然没有摆脱的一种想法。即使像《瑞克和莫蒂》这样的东西，也是丹·哈蒙对不得不与这种模式对话并嘲笑它的恼火，但他仍然在与它对话。我们还没有找到摆脱英雄之旅的方法。如果你不熟悉它，你可能需要查一下。再说一次，我无法在2-3小时的内容中解释我引用的每一件事，但这种文化已经为魔法做好了准备。星球大战不是科幻小说。它是设定在太空中的奇幻故事。星球大战不是星际迷航。它不是关于，哦，生物在攻击我们。
Why don't we reverse engineer the electron drives and we'll overload it. Like putting too much air into a balloon. It's not that. Like it's wizards with swords. Like it is knights. It is a culture rediscovering religion that doesn't believe that the Jedi's are real, but really there's this energy that lives in our hearts like it is Dungeons and Dragons The US government and its infinite wisdom at this port just starts to explore consciousness because Jung has Challenged what we think is possible and so by the 50s You know through the 70s
为什么我们不逆向工程电子驱动器，我们会使它过载。就像往气球里充太多空气一样。不是那样的。就像带着剑的巫师。就像骑士。这是一种重新发现宗教的文化，它不相信绝地武士是真实的，但实际上有一种能量活在我们的心中，就像它是《龙与地下城》。美国政府及其无限的智慧在此时开始探索意识，因为荣格挑战了我们认为可能的极限，所以到了50年代
We feel like the Soviets are researching We feel like the Soviets are researching psychics, so we have to too. Like yeah, maybe the microchip and the fighter jet are not going to be the weapon of the future. They don't know in 1955. A lot of the fighter jets that are not even made until the 80s, the early drafts of them start being made in 1955, 1962. Like a lot of these things take a lot of time to actualize, and we don't always know what's going.
我们觉得苏联正在研究通灵者，所以我们也必须研究。就像，是的，也许微芯片和战斗机不会成为未来的武器。他们在1955年不知道。很多直到80年代才制造出来的战斗机，它们的早期草图在1955年、1962年就开始制作了。很多这些事情需要很长时间才能实现，我们并不总是知道发生了什么。
And so the US military industrial complex in DARPA are pretty good at throwing a million irons in the fire, which is pretty expensive and become the basis of our economy, but that's a different conversation. You have people like Uri Geller on TV bending spoons spoons with their mind and most people think that it's real you have remote viewers who are trying to see into Soviet installations because like you get two identical twins and you put one in a room and then you say like well this one looked At a rose and this other one drew this thing that's red. So maybe they could Remote view that was something that we spent millions of dollars trying to do was basically like see things with the mind because we didn't know how far the collective unconscious went and you have you know
所以美国军工复合体和DARPA非常擅长把一百万个铁器扔进火里，这非常昂贵，并成为我们经济的基础，但那是另一回事。你有像尤里·盖勒这样的人在电视上用他们的思想弯曲勺子，大多数人认为这是真的。你有远程观察者试图看穿苏联的设施，因为就像你得到两个同卵双胞胎，你把一个放在房间里，然后你说，好吧，这个看了一朵玫瑰，另一个画了这个红色的东西。所以也许他们可以远程观察，这是我们花费数百万美元试图做的事情，基本上就是用思想看东西，因为我们不知道集体无意识走了多远，你有，你知道
reports that they're declassified now largely that you can look up from this era where people are being like maybe there's a quantum field that makes atoms but we also interact with it and certain individuals see this like a wavelength. I mean stuff that's the height of New Age was actually given millions of dollars. You know, there were, you know, things like the first Earth Battalion project. They tried to create these, like, modern, you know, super soldier warrior monks by getting them to stare at goats and then seeing if any of the goats died and had heart attack and then being like oh wow maybe this is like the next generation of the the future wars won't be fought with guns they'll be fought with the
现在很大程度上已经解密的报告，你可以从这个时代查到，人们说也许有一个制造原子的量子场，但我们也与它互动，某些人像波长一样看到这一点。我的意思是，新时代高度的东西实际上被给予了数百万美元。你知道，有像第一地球营项目这样的事情。他们试图通过让这些现代超级战士武士僧侣盯着山羊看，然后看看是否有任何山羊死亡并心脏病发作，然后说，哦哇，也许这是下一代，未来的战争将不会用枪打，它们将用
mind it turns out that like goats just have heart attacks and die a lot also some of them faint and then like probably no one was killing them with their mind there's a bad movie that George Clooney made if you want to explore that period. It's not terribly accurate, but it's probably a lot more fun than the actual history there. So if Reich was right about energy, if Jung was right about the collective unconscious, if the mystics were right about these things, maybe the other form of government structure, communism, was going to get ahead of capitalism and we needed to explore them if we really believe what we said that we believed about power and the nature of
思想打。事实证明，山羊只是经常心脏病发作并死亡，有些还会昏倒，然后可能没有人用思想杀死它们。如果你想探索那个时期，乔治·克鲁尼拍了一部糟糕的电影。它不是很准确，但可能比那里的实际历史有趣得多。所以如果赖希关于能量的说法是对的，如果荣格关于集体无意识的说法是对的，如果神秘主义者关于这些事情的说法是对的，也许另一种政府结构，共产主义，会领先于资本主义，我们需要探索它们，如果我们真的相信我们所说的关于权力和本质的
you know economy. Enter John C. Lilly. This brings us to dolphins. John C. Lilly was a serious neuroscientist. He mapped the brain's pain and pleasure centers. He invented the isolation tank. But somewhere between the sensory deprivation tank and the ketamine, he'd gone kind of full mystic. There's a million movies that directly say they're based on Lily, and then there's a million movies that don't, but they probably are. Like if you dislike in Star Trek 3 or something, I'm not a Trekkie, where they go back in time to save a whale, they don't directly say that Lily is the reason that they do that, but I'm pretty sure that he's the reason
你知道经济。进入约翰·C·利里。这把我们带到了海豚。约翰·C·利里是一位严肃的神经科学家。他绘制了大脑的疼痛和快乐中心。他发明了隔离舱。但在感觉剥夺舱和氯胺酮之间的某个地方，他已经完全变成了神秘主义者。有数百万部电影直接说它们基于利里，然后有数百万部电影没有说，但它们可能也是。就像如果你不喜欢《星际迷航3》之类的，我不是星际迷，他们回到过去拯救鲸鱼，他们没有直接说利里是他们这样做的原因，但我很确定他是原因
that's in the screenwriter's head. Lily believes that because cetaceans were also mammalian and they had really big brains, cetaceans are whales, FYI, and they had these sonic abilities to talk through sound, which doesn't really sound that deep when you realize that like language, like this podcast is also through sound, but I don't know, people mythologize like whales a lot in the 70s, that they had cracked this code of consciousness. Maybe we could talk to them or they were just speaking another language like Spanish that you could translate and then you could ask them to work as spies.
在编剧的脑子里。利里认为，因为鲸类动物也是哺乳动物，而且它们有非常大的大脑，鲸类动物是鲸鱼，顺便说一下，它们有这些通过声音说话的声波能力，当你意识到语言，就像这个播客也是通过声音时，这听起来并不那么深刻，但我不知道，人们在70年代把鲸鱼神话化了很多，认为它们破解了意识的密码。也许我们可以和它们交谈，或者它们只是在说另一种语言，比如西班牙语，你可以翻译，然后你可以要求它们作为间谍工作。
Or at least that's how he sold it to the military. And he was like, well, I'll just talk to the dolphins and I'll tell them to tell you where the Russian subs are and then you won't have to worry about like active and passive radar and all these things and they were like, okay So NASA and the CIA fund him a lot or the CIA funds him through NASA or DARPA funds the CIA through NASA the bit all of it goes back whatever anyway, so Because you're in this world now where you have Raichian breakthroughs, you have Jungian visions, you have people that are believing in this sort of like infinite expansive consciousness that we don't really know, science hasn't ruled out all the places it hasn't, it
或者至少他是这样把它卖给军方的。他说，好吧，我只是和海豚交谈，我会告诉它们告诉你们俄罗斯潜艇在哪里，然后你们就不必担心主动和被动雷达以及所有这些事情了，他们说，好吧。所以NASA和CIA资助了他很多，或者CIA通过NASA资助他，或者DARPA通过NASA资助CIA，所有这些都回到了，无论如何，所以因为你现在处于这个世界，你有赖希式的突破，你有荣格式的愿景，你有相信这种无限扩张意识的人，我们真的不知道，科学还没有排除所有它还没有
can't go yet. They haven't decided that these things don't work. Somebody like John C. Lilly can go to the CIA and say, hey, I think one of the reasons why dolphins haven't spoken English yet is that no one gave them LSD. But I think if you give dolphins LSD and they have a pretty good teacher, maybe they can talk to people. And what's more than that, maybe those dolphins eventually will let us talk to God. I don't think he, I think that was like his intention
去过的地方。他们还没有决定这些东西不起作用。像约翰·C·利里这样的人可以去CIA说，嘿，我认为海豚还没有说英语的原因之一是没人给它们LSD。但我认为如果你给海豚LSD，而且它们有一个很好的老师，也许它们可以和人交谈。不仅如此，也许那些海豚最终会让我们和上帝交谈。我不认为他，我认为那是他的意图
was the talk to God part, but the discover Russian subs and you can talk to dolphins was probably the sales pitch to get the millions of dollars. Cut to 1965. Margaret Hal Lovett. She's young. She's in her 20s. She's in a bathing suit. She's in a flooded house with a dolphin named Peter and her job is to teach the dolphin English and so she spends months in waste deep water in a specially constructed house in the Caribbean and Peter is given LSD with the other dolphins but he doesn't learn English. Instead, he becomes very attached to her, and he just tries to mate. And so there's not ethics committees and research.
是和上帝交谈的部分，但发现俄罗斯潜艇和你可以和海豚交谈可能是为了获得数百万美元的推销词。切到1965年。玛格丽特·豪·洛维特。她很年轻。她在20多岁。她穿着泳衣。她在加勒比海一个专门建造的房子里，在一个被淹没的房子里，和一只名叫彼得的海豚在一起，她的工作是教海豚英语，所以她在齐腰深的水里度过了几个月，彼得和其他海豚一起被给予了LSD，但他没有学会英语。相反，他变得非常依恋她，他只是试图交配。所以没有伦理委员会和研究。
What you would call conventional wisdom is also probably pretty different than what you would call conventional wisdom and research today, or what would be allowed. Anyway, the dolphin becomes very attracted to the researcher, and so Lily says, we'll just go ahead and stimulate him sexually, and maybe then he'll learn English, which doesn't work, but it's one of the things that becomes part of their protocols. John C. Lily, meanwhile, is getting really distracted. He's taking heroic doses of ketamine and sitting in an isolation tank,
你所说的传统智慧可能也与你今天在研究中所说的传统智慧相当不同，或者与今天所允许的相当不同。无论如何，海豚对研究人员变得非常有吸引力，所以利里说，我们直接在性方面刺激他，也许那时他就会学会英语，这不起作用，但这是成为他们协议一部分的事情之一。与此同时，约翰·C·利里变得非常分心。他正在服用英雄剂量的氯胺酮，坐在隔离舱里，
and he's mapping what he calls the cognitive multi-state cosmos, which he says he can contact entities that he calls Echo or Earth Consciousness Control Office. So he's like sort of going into his own mind in a way where he's like losing touch with reality. Interesting aside here. John C. Lilly doing this doesn't result in anything cool, but the William Hurt movie, Altered States, not the clothing store for evangelical Christians, but the movie, Altered States, is based on his work. So is the Mike Nichols follow-up to The Graduate, which is called Day of the Dolphin, which is a bad movie.
他正在绘制他所谓的认知多状态宇宙，他说他可以联系他称为Echo或地球意识控制办公室的实体。所以他有点进入了他自己的思想，以一种他与现实失去联系的方式。这里有一个有趣的题外话。约翰·C·利里这样做并没有产生任何酷的东西，但威廉·赫特的电影《变形博士》，不是福音派基督徒的服装店，而是电影《变形博士》，是基于他的工作。迈克·尼科尔斯继《毕业生》之后的电影也是如此，叫《海豚日》，那是一部糟糕的电影。
And then also, like, if you played Echo the Dolphin, where you shoot, like, echolocation on Sega Genesis, like, from the 90s, if you're my age, if you use that in that game you shoot like echolocation at giant quartz crystals to talk to like Atlantean spirits to let you travel through time to fight aliens, which is pretty wild when you say it out loud but games didn't have like it was an implied story at that point because we didn't have like video cutscenes and things like we do now. Those are all based on him and probably a lot more. He also lives long enough that he sees the invention of YouTube and when I'm in early college and YouTube is brand new you can see John Lilly on these like early like video like Windows 3.0 not even 3.1 like XP Programs talking about how like whales have a soul that lets us travel through time or something
然后还有，就像，如果你玩过《海豚埃可》，你在世嘉创世纪上射击回声定位，如果你和我一样大，如果你在那个游戏中射击回声定位到巨大的石英晶体，与亚特兰蒂斯的灵魂交谈，让你穿越时间去对抗外星人，当你大声说出来时，这非常狂野，但游戏当时没有像视频过场动画那样的东西，因为我们没有像现在这样的东西。这些都基于他，可能还有更多。他也活得足够长，看到了YouTube的发明，当我在大学早期，YouTube是全新的，你可以看到约翰·利里在这些早期的视频上，像Windows 3.0，甚至不是3.1，像XP程序，谈论鲸鱼如何拥有让我们穿越时间的灵魂什么的
I don't know if those have been taken down they used to be up anyway a side over so When this is all happening You know the 70s are rapidly becoming the 80s the crisis of confidence is something that didn't work Where Carter comes out and says maybe America should have like a different myth The 70s are rapidly becoming the 80s. The crisis of confidence is something that didn't work. Where Carter comes out and says, maybe America should have a different myth. Maybe we should redefine progress. Maybe we should redefine our purpose. Maybe we should redefine the American dream as not cutting your grass and eating six servings
我不知道那些是否被删除了，它们曾经在上面。无论如何，题外话结束。所以当这一切发生时，你知道70年代正在迅速变成80年代，信心危机是行不通的事情。卡特出来说也许美国应该有不同的神话。70年代正在迅速变成80年代。信心危机是行不通的事情。卡特出来说，也许美国应该有不同的神话。也许我们应该重新定义进步。也许我们应该重新定义我们的目的。也许我们应该重新定义美国梦，不是修剪草坪和吃六份
of red meat a day and having cheap things manufactured in other countries, maybe there's like a community or something else that we could have or we could, you know, do like an FDR type project or like have a war on poverty or like green energy or something else. That project largely fails or is at least rejected by the American public. I mean, at the same time, there is somebody, I don't know their name, and they probably didn't admit who they were or what magazine they were reading, reads an episode of, I don't know what you call those, I don't subscribe, I swear, but like a story in Hustler that
红肉一天，在其他国家制造廉价的东西，也许有一个社区或其他我们可以拥有的东西，或者我们可以，你知道，做一个像FDR那样的项目，或者进行一场反贫困战争，或者绿色能源什么的。那个项目很大程度上失败了，或者至少被美国公众拒绝了。我的意思是，与此同时，有一个人，我不知道他们的名字，他们可能没有承认他们是谁或他们在读什么杂志，读了一集，我不知道你们怎么称呼那些，我发誓我不订阅，但像《好色客》里的一篇故事，
is based on the work that NASA is funding about a woman who is having relations with a dolphin, and they claim this is true, the person looks it up and they're like, oh my gosh, like, we are paying for this stuff. And they ask their boss at NASA, why are we paying for this stuff? And then NASA says, funding is over. What are you doing jacking off dolphins that are on LSD? We're going to like not pay for this anymore and this point of consciousness and experimentation for the American public at least for the government's
基于NASA资助的工作，关于一个正在与海豚发生关系的女人，他们声称这是真的，那个人查了一下，他们就像，天哪，我们正在为这些东西买单。他们问他们在NASA的老板，我们为什么要为这些东西买单？然后NASA说，资金结束了。你们在干什么，给服用LSD的海豚打手枪？我们不会再为这个买单了，这个意识和实验的点，至少对于美国公众来说，对于政府的
ability to pay for it is now over. Somebody like Aaron Beck has been watching this chaos and he has this different idea. He's seen, you know, in 78, 900 people drink Kool-Aid and die in Jonestown. At Eastland, he's seen these boundaries dissolve between therapists and clients where there's people who are having these encounter groups, but then everyone's having sex later and it becomes this reliving of trauma instead of a treating of it He's seen people that are having psychotic breaks being give LSD and people that are having like legitimate schizophrenia Being encouraged to go into it to like talk to crystals by psychotherapists in California who are saying that it's a legitimate
支付能力来说，现在结束了。像亚伦·贝克这样的人一直在观察这种混乱，他有不同的想法。他看到，你知道，在78年，900人在琼斯镇喝了毒药死亡。在东兰，他看到治疗师和客户之间的界限消失了，那里有人在进行这些遭遇小组，但后来每个人都在事后发生性关系，这变成了创伤的重演，而不是治疗。他看到有精神崩溃的人被给予LSD，而有合法精神分裂症的人被心理治疗师鼓励进入它，去和水晶交谈，在加利福尼亚，他们说这是一种合法的
therapeutic encounter or spiritual emergence. He's seen like Werner Eckhardt, or Erdhardt, I never knew how to say his name, who is probably the proto cult leader for somebody like Keith Renear of NXIVM, you know, lock people up in hotel ballrooms and not let them pee, and then break them down with verbal abuse and then sell them Enlightenment like that's Buddhism He's seen all of the hippies that like had this unlimited potential when they smoked
治疗性遭遇或精神觉醒。他看到像沃纳·埃克哈特，或者埃尔哈特，我从来不知道怎么念他的名字，他可能是像NXIVM的基思·拉尼尔这样的原型邪教领袖，你知道，把人锁在酒店宴会厅里，不让他们撒尿，然后用言语虐待摧毁他们，然后把启蒙卖给他们，就像那是佛教。他看到所有那些在抽烟时有无限潜力的嬉皮士
Weed and like painted bright wings on a rock or whatever they did Like lose their enchantment with that and start to do heroin and start to steal things. He's watching society break down. He sees this beautiful fusion of Jung's map and Reich's method in the worst way, that it's become a circus, that psychoanalysis takes forever, that it's overly subjective, that it makes everything up, and then it's kind of bullshit when people aren't given rules that make it not bullshit. And he's been watching this chaos and he has a different idea. And he says, what if we threw all of that out? Reich's body, Jung's soul, Pearl's experiments, you know, experiments and theatrics. What if we get rid of like, Freud's nonsense?
大麻，在石头上画明亮的翅膀什么的，失去对它的着迷，开始吸食海洛因，开始偷东西。他看着社会崩溃。他以最糟糕的方式看到了荣格地图和赖希方法的这种美丽融合，它变成了一个马戏团，精神分析需要永远，它过于主观，它编造了一切，然后当人们没有被给予规则使它不成为胡说八道时，它就是一种胡说八道。他一直在观察这种混乱，他有不同的想法。他说，如果我们把所有这些都扔掉呢？赖希的身体，荣格的灵魂，珀尔斯的实验，你知道，实验和戏剧。如果我们摆脱像弗洛伊德的胡说八道呢？
The whole messy mystical tradition. What if we return this to a medical procedure? What if we get rid of like, Freud's nonsense? The whole messy mystical tradition. What if we return this to a medical procedure? What if the mind was just a computer? What if depression was just bad programming? What if we could just debug the psyche like it's software, it's clean, it's measurable, and the 80s is now happening, the stock market is going up, the crisis of confidence is going over, no touching, no screaming, no dolphins. Just cognition leading to behavior that you are in control of and you can change.
整个混乱的神秘传统。如果我们把它恢复成一种医疗程序呢？如果思想只是一个计算机呢？如果抑郁症只是糟糕的编程呢？如果我们能像调试软件一样调试心灵呢，它是干净的，可测量的，80年代现在正在发生，股市正在上涨，信心危机正在结束，没有触摸，没有尖叫，没有海豚。只有导致你可以控制并可以改变的行为的认知。
Isn't that an empowering hero myth for America to take back after this time? I don't know that Aaron Beck is really the salesman than any of these people were. I don't think he has the insight that half of them did. I think he understands institutions and he understood what was going to work and what was probably inevitable. And even though I don't like CBT, I don't see Aaron Beck really as like a bad guy. I see him as an inevitability and a system that had been given so much slack that it hung itself. So they drained the pools. They sent the dolphins to a park in
这难道不是一个赋予美国在此时期后夺回的英雄神话吗？我不知道亚伦·贝克是否真的是比这些人更好的推销员。我不认为他有他们中一半人的洞察力。我认为他了解机构，他了解什么会起作用，什么可能是不可避免的。即使我不喜欢CBT，我也不认为亚伦·贝克是一个坏人。我看他是一个必然，一个被给予了太多松懈以至于它自缢的系统。所以他们排干了池子。他们把海豚送到墨西哥的一个公园，
Mexico, I believe, where they decided to willfully drown themselves because they wanted to go back to the lady in the LSD and the relationship that they no longer could be a part of. relationship that they no longer could be a part of. Reich had found trauma in the body. Jung had mapped its archetypal pattern. Perls had shown how to work directly with it. And there's a generation of really brilliant misfits who had kind of recklessly, you know, I'm leaving Eric Erickson, or I'm leaving Milton Erickson and people like that out of this, but there's a million examples, you know, had fused the semantic and symbolic creating
我相信，在那里他们决定故意淹死自己，因为他们想回到那个服用LSD的女士身边，回到他们无法再参与的关系中。赖希在身体里发现了创伤。荣格绘制了它的原型模式。珀尔斯展示了如何直接与它工作。有一代非常聪明的怪人，他们有点鲁莽地，你知道，我把埃里克·埃里克森，或者米尔顿·埃里克森这样的人排除在外，但有数百万个例子，你知道，融合了躯体和象征，创造了
therapeutic approach in this way that could actually heal with their own intuition and their own ethics. And then the people who followed them were more reckless. And they didn't learn from the ethics. Because the ethics didn't exist. They were implied. And people are kind of dumb. And when you say, hey, this is cool, it works works then they just treat this stuff like it's a magic trick and they get
这种治疗方法，可以用他们自己的直觉和他们自己的道德真正治愈。然后跟随他们的人更鲁莽。他们没有从道德中学习。因为道德不存在。它们是隐含的。人们有点笨。当你告诉他们，嘿，这很酷，它起作用，然后他们只是把这些东西当作魔术，他们让
people hurt and that's what happened and so America threw all of it away because in our quest to find the bottom of consciousness we found things that scared us that didn't fit in our filing cabinets or insurance forms or in the profit motive or within the capitalist structure that we needed to defeat Russia and we didn't really find the objectivism that we were looking for and so we decided that consciousness didn't have a bottom. We didn't need to find the bottom of it. It actually didn't exist. We're just thoughts. We're just cognitive distortions. We're just inputs and outputs that can be programmed by an
人们受伤，这就是发生的事情，所以美国把所有这些都扔掉了，因为在我们寻找意识底部的过程中，我们发现了让我们害怕的东西，这些东西不适合我们的档案柜或保险表格，或者利润动机，或者我们需要击败俄罗斯的资本主义结构，我们并没有真正找到我们正在寻找的客观性，所以我们决定意识没有底部。我们不需要找到它的底部。它实际上并不存在。我们只是思想。我们只是认知扭曲。我们只是输入和输出，可以被编程，由一个
algorithm like, you know, in those days vacuum tubes or in these days Facebook just cognitive distortions, or just inputs and outputs that can be programmed by an algorithm, like you know, in those days vacuum tubes, or in these days Facebook, and that people are just sort of incentive structures, and the body, that's not where trauma lives, the unconscious, that's just superstition. Pull yourself up by your bootstraps, get over it, if you don't get over it, it's not societal oppression, it's not racism, it's not, you know, inherent, you know, things built into capitalism. It's just that you didn't work as hard or pray as much or like have as much faith or have as much gumption or some other made-up concept and
算法，就像，你知道，在那些日子里的真空管，或者在这些日子里的Facebook，只是认知扭曲，或者只是输入和输出，可以被编程，由一个算法，就像你知道，在那些日子里的真空管，或者在这些日子里的Facebook，人们只是某种激励结构，而身体，那不是创伤居住的地方，无意识，那只是迷信。靠自己的努力站起来，克服它，如果你克服不了它，那不是社会压迫，不是种族主义，不是，你知道，内在的，你知道，资本主义中内置的东西。只是你没有那么努力工作，或者没有祈祷那么多，或者没有那么多的信仰，或者没有那么多的进取心，或者其他一些编造的概念，而
these were easier ways for us to see ourself. But Reich's legacy lived on, and the body does keep the score. But Reich's legacy lived on, and the body does keep the score. Despite what you think about Reich, he was undisputedly the first somatic psychotherapist, and he recognized very early what people like Bessel van der Kolk would later describe decades later. And everyone is an outsider weirdo until their ideas are copied, and people like Reich and Jung had their ideas copied a lot, even if you don't know who they are. Reich had bad ideas and he had good ones, and give him credit where credits do, but
这些是我们看待自己的更简单的方式。但赖希的遗产活了下来，身体确实记录了分数。但赖希的遗产活了下来，身体确实记录了分数。尽管你对赖希有什么看法，他无疑是第一位躯体心理治疗师，他很早就认识到了像贝塞尔·范德科尔克几十年后会描述的东西。每个人都是局外人怪人，直到他们的想法被复制，像赖希和荣格这样的人的想法被复制了很多，即使你不知道他们是谁。赖希有坏主意，也有好主意，功劳归功于他，但是
the fear of these depths created the perfect condition for the, say, Tannic panic. They created the perfect conditions for the worst applications of Reagan and Reaganomics and the American conservatism and Wall Street worship that became the 80s and when you exhale the body and the shadow they don't disappear they return in the most twisted forms imaginable and when they do they bring demons. Mr. Rudyard Kipling's famous poem entitled Boots. Those of us who have never been engaged in actual warfare have very little idea of some of its worst horrors.
对这些深度的恐惧为撒旦恐慌创造了完美的条件。他们为里根和里根经济学以及成为80年代的美国保守主义和华尔街崇拜的最糟糕应用创造了完美的条件，当你呼出身体和阴影时，它们不会消失，它们以你能想象到的最扭曲的形式回归，当它们回归时，它们带来了恶魔。鲁德亚德·吉卜林先生著名的诗《靴子》。我们这些从未参与过实际战争的人，对它的一些最严重的恐怖几乎没有概念。
One of the most terrible being the agonized impressions made upon the minds of the infantry soldiers during the long long forced marches. Soldiers have been known to go absolutely insane with the everlasting sight of marching feet all around them. Boots moving up and down again, there's no discharge in the war, can so damn fine moving up and down again I try to think of something different Oh my god, keep me from going lunatic Move, move, move, move Moving up and down again No discharging I have to think of something different
最可怕的事情之一是长途强行军期间步兵士兵心中产生的痛苦印象。众所周知，士兵们因为周围永无止境的行军脚步声而变得绝对疯狂。靴子上下移动，战争中没有解脱，该死的靴子上下移动，我试着想点别的东西，天哪，别让我发疯，走，走，走，走，上下移动，没有解脱，我必须想点别的东西
Oh my god, keep me from going lunatic Move, move, move, move Moving up and down again There's no discharge in the war! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
天哪，别让我发疯，走，走，走，走，上下移动，战争中没有解脱！这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。